[Music]
we work the man oh no this isn't about
the father this is about the son Artemis
Fowl
[Applause]
you grown strong son and smarter but I
have her imagine them take me with you
don't I have no arty it's just one very
important thing I have to do
[Music]
authorities launched a worldwide manhunt
for the famous collector he is suspected
to have been behind some of the biggest
robberies ever
hello your family has taken something of
great value from us return it to me or I
will destroy everything else
[Music]
anyone's supposed to see this yet
[Music]
your father is in a complicated
profession for years he is protected
powerful secrets that have kept mankind
safe from the dangers of another world
it's time to face your destiny but we
are not alone in this most items is a
talented giant Worf and I'm Holly short
your ally on the other side
it's real
[Music]
alright save my father save the world
be ready felony object he's gonna head
on to miss I'm scared to death
he's coming
see
thank you
I'm the next criminal mastermind
this is what they call greatness I
didn't read much on trolls anything else
to do cake for the teeth baby people
good to know
[Music]